all right misha
yes misha where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i'm from reno nevada
reno it's a tiny little mountain town in
northern nevada yes i know reno oh yeah
everybody that knows reno they either
love it or they hate it it's like a
third rate las vegas it is exactly it's
like a dealers d minus list las vegas
for sure and tell me about your
childhood
i actually had a really wonderful
childhood i had a childhood
that
was very blessed and we lived in a
household that was very
supportive
and
they glorified our achievements but we
were never punished for our failures
and so it was an environment that really
bred positivity
and individualism
so
i really i really had a blessed
childhood which is
kind of weird for people to accept
because they expect
people in sex work in the adult industry
especially to have some kind of
childhood trauma or damage or come from
a broken home and i did not come from a
broken home my father is an attorney my
mother worked at starbucks for 13 years
and it really was just a wonderful
wonderful childhood and i had every
opportunity available to me that i
wanted
and i went to college
my degree paths i double majored in
psychology and political science with an
emphasis in foreign affairs so i value
my education over everything that i have
thank you
and yet you still chose this path and i
did and that's what people find highly
uh peculiar and unusual
is that how could somebody that comes
from
a
mostly normal background with an
education
ever decide to turn to sex work
and
i've always been interested in the adult
entertainment world from a very young
age i wanted to be in porn
and
how young in age i was about eight or
nine years old and i think like at that
age where does an eight eight-year-old
even get exposed to porn true
you know i was never really exposed to
actually hardcore porn i was more
exposed to
the
female figures of playboy and baywatch
and that's what's out there everywhere
it's everywhere it's more of the
mainstream iconic figures
when i was in high school i had a
picture of jenna jameson in my room and
most people would find that you know
grotesque or
that these women are
foul and you know they're just perverse
[ __ ]
and to me i was someone who was bullied
my whole life those women in my mind
they weren't
disgusting they were they were very
beautiful empowering strong demanding or
commanding i guess you could say uh
their presence was so powerful so i
didn't see perversion i saw power
and i think when you can harness that
sexual energy it does give you a sense
of power
and for me who is just terrified of
everyone my whole life i craved that i
wanted that
so
to become that was the ultimate goal in
my mind because then people would like
you and accept you and you'd have a
platform and have all this power to do
anything you wanted to do and just
conquer the world and that's what i
decided to do
and you started this well you started
sex work at what age i started sex work
at 18
and
i was in and out i had my toe in and out
of the adult industry for about 10 years
i was in um i was into bdsm adult
modeling i started doing a little bit of
video stuff here and there but never for
big companies or anybody really
reputable
so
and because of this stigma the socially
constructed idea that porn is inherently
bad and negative um
i
bought into that in a way like as as
much as i'm
such a proponent for
sex work and for
you know being in that industry
and everyone in that industry i did buy
it you buy into it you buy into that
stigma a little bit
where
you can't help but second-guess yourself
and i had a professor
i was um in college
and they
i told them that i wanted to do porn i
have no shame in admitting that and he
pulled me aside and i was like oh great
i'm going to get in trouble now because
i
want to do porn and it wasn't even the
nature of
what i said it was the fact that i
wanted to do porn when i had the ability
to do
literally anything else and they were
disappointed and that was really
devastating to me because i'm like why
does it have to be that way
why
do you have to be damaged or
have it be a last-ditch resort it should
just be something like everything else
it's a job it's a career and that
doesn't define my character it doesn't
define me as a mother or as a friend or
as a lover or anything else it's that's
my job
and to be
totally ostracized by society because of
something that you do for a living that
a mass a majority of the population
consumes i've never been able to
understand that so it was kind of my
mission to
change that perspective um and using
myself as a martyr for that cause i
guess too
and i will tell you that it's
far more difficult than i ever imagined
a lot of harsh judgment it's a lot and
i can deal with the judgment from other
people because i've accepted that
that other people are never going to
necessarily agree with what you do
my hope would be that you don't have to
agree which i would hope
that
some
point you come
to
you'll realize that there are other
people in this world
that exist and have different opinions
and different viewpoints on the world
and they have every right to exist and
be happy just as much as you do
so it's not even changing people's minds
to get them to accept it fully it's just
to acknowledge our existence and our
same right to
the things that they have
to
so
it was much more difficult than i ever
expected and it
came from
people within my own family and friends
of mine and
having people look you in the eye and
say
you can't come to our family dinners
anymore
our children can't play together
those kind of things are devastating
because when it comes from a third party
and a stranger you anticipate that kind
of judgment and shame
but to hear it from within your own
circle it's how am i supposed to change
the world or even just the perspective
of people that are immediately opposed
to me
when i can't even
change the minds of some people in my
circle
and that was the most devastating part
to me is to hear that from people
but
as soon as that blow the the pain from
the blow subsides
then it just makes it that much more
important
to change it
and so it enhances
my drive
and um you know this hunger that i have
to try to prove a point do you feel like
americans are uptight about sex oh 100
i think americans have it's such a
repressed it's not just americans no
it's not but i think uh it's
kind of ironic that in america it's
actually the europeans are probably much
more open they are very much so open
very much so open in europe far more so
than than in america um
and a lot of you know this repression is
rooted in religion
and it's unfortunate because you see
often these situations the people that
are the the harshest opponents and
critics
are the ones who are secretly engaging
in um
taboo things themselves exactly so it's
the biggest hypocrites are the ones that
usually are um
consuming
more than anyone else if we had an open
and honest conversation about sex
we could make a huge difference in this
world i i truly believe that
that would make a difference
so that's what i want to start those
uncomfortable conversations and have
them uh we're all sexual creatures we're
all products of sex we all have sex we
all consume sex at some point so
this taboo
um
feelings and the stigma this negative
energy that's attached to sex in general
and even our own bodies
and particularly sex work in the adult
industry
it's
dangerous um and it's it's terrifying i
get death threats regularly
um
i had people say
the most horrible things to me that i
couldn't even imagine
like
saying to anyone let alone a complete
stranger strictly based on what i do for
a living
i've had threats against my family
and all kinds of just really horrible
things and i don't even blame those
people i feel sorry for them
but that again makes it all the more
important that we
open up the conversation and try
to shed light into the human side of
this industry we're all human beings at
the end of the day
and regardless of what we do for work
we are all humans i'm someone's daughter
i'm someone's mother
so i should be entitled to the same
rights even to live and to work and
to happiness and health like everyone
else so
[Music]
so you you've been a poor actress for
how long
i've actually only been in industry porn
for two years and i've um
multi-award nominated at this point um
i haven't won any yet fingers crossed i
have one tomorrow what have you been
nominated um performer of the year is
the biggest one
i
have a showcase dvd
called the exploitation of misha montana
which is actually a documentary style
showcase
that i did last year
and it's unlike anything that's ever
been done in the adult industry because
it opened up into my personal life
and no one's ever really done it to that
extent i shared and sacrificed
everything for that um every element of
privacy
everything
i talk about my family and my son and
all these different things and i
i'm lucky enough that it was so
critically acclaimed and it was accepted
by the adult community it was nominated
for every single major award show as a
best feature
and so now it's six total nominations
for best movie
so
would you describe yourself as happy
with this career i'm so happy and i
struggled for so long
with
going back and forth between i worked as
an executive assistant for a major
politician in nevada
and
i
worked in law firms i was going to go to
law school i had all these different
career paths chosen for me
and i was never fulfilled
and i knew deep down that's what i
wanted to do and i wasn't being honest
to myself
even though i'm capable and intelligent
enough to do those things and had all
the resources and the tools that a lot
of people don't have
this is what i wanted to do
and
it brings me so much joy but it gives me
so much purpose in my life too
especially because i suffered a stroke
last year
and
that was the highlight of the
documentary
how old are you i'm 32 32 and you
suffered a stroke i had a stroke so what
was the cause of that i had a stroke
from the kobit 19 vaccine
uh that caused a blood clot that
traveled to my heart
and at the time i wasn't aware that i
had a heart condition
i had what they call a pfo which is a
hole in your heart
so when i had the clot it broke off and
it went to my heart and my heart pumped
it through the hole to the left side of
my brain so i was right side stroke
affected i lost all feeling in my face
and it drooped out i lost control of my
the right side of my body completely i
couldn't talk
um
and it was frightening frightening
experience to
to have and consequently i had heart
surgery about a month later
but i went when i went to the hospital i
was in about five days
and
the whole time i was just so concerned
about my career more than anything
obviously first and foremost being alive
but i mean my career was a close second
i
was planning my comeback scene from my
hospital bed and so two weeks later i
had a full heart monitor on and i
actually did a scene a full scene with a
heart monitor around two weeks later
and people thought i was crazy for doing
that they still do
um it was nominated so there's that so
you're very open i'm very open very open
about everything that's going on
everything well and so that gave me the
opportunity it was kind of the tool that
i needed i've always wanted to advocate
for the human side of this industry from
the beginning and it was
this weird unexpected gift in the form
of tragedy that
i used as an opportunity at a second
chance and with a second chance i won't
waste it so i've become an advocate for
stroke awareness and
as ironic as it is
people message me hundreds of messages
that i've gotten from survivors from
people that
have had a family member that's had a
stroke or other major illness
and they thank me for being open about
it because it's not difficult or it's
not easy to put yourself out there
even when you're already in the
spotlight i was always very uh the most
publicly private person i would give you
exactly what i wanted to and reserve my
my very private parts of my life for
myself so when you rip that wide open to
the whole world and nothing is secret
and nothing is sacred
it's difficult psychologically to go
through that and emotionally but to me
it is absolutely worth it if i can be
the martyr for this cause i have to
share everything if i'm i can't be a
hypocrite i have to share
literally everything the good the bad
and the ugly i am going to be honest and
transparent with everything that i do in
the hopes that you see me as a human
being and you see that hey i have the
same struggles that you have or someone
you may know you know has and i still
won't let that
fill me with resentment or hatred and it
will be something that i hope you find
inspiring and at least give you
the strength to get out of bed in the
morning and do something that you may
not have thought you could do
so
i want to be an uplifting figure the
best that i can be
and in so doing i have to sacrifice some
elements of my life to do that and it is
worth it to me as difficult as it is
from time to time
and being a porn actress you
technology has changed things a lot it
has and is it more difficult to make
money now it is it's extremely difficult
um it's highly competitive now it's a
really saturated market and you're
competing against amateurs oh yeah i
mean the girl the barista down the
street hasn't only fans now so it's like
it's just this and that's dangerous in
itself too because as much as i support
sex work and i think everyone that wants
to do this career should have the
opportunity to do it and
go in you know
knowing that they can make money and
make it a successful lucrative long term
career
you have to understand that
just because something became popular it
doesn't erase
the consequences it's you are
sacrificing potentially every other
opportunity
as much as i hate that idea and i'm
working to fight against it it's still
reality unfortunately there's a lot of
stigma i guess there's so much stigma
and
that just because it's become popular
doesn't mean that that goes away so i
always tell people i fully support your
decision to get into porn i hope people
that are looking to get into porn would
reach out to someone like myself
because it can be overwhelming and
dangerous and competitive and there's
things that you never thought in a
million years you'd have to know that
you need to know
legalities and you know things about
your health and getting tested regularly
and all these different elements that go
into this business that people are just
completely ignorant of
and i always tell them
if you want to do porn you imagine every
other door that you had open closing
and are you okay with that and also
imagine the person that you would
not want to hear that you're doing porn
their reaction
and would you still do it
because i'll tell you right now from
personal experience all of those things
are true
and
they're very difficult to deal with
emotionally very difficult
so if you can do that and accept that
and
that's something that you can want to
continue to do and go forward with then
i fully support that decision but you
have to be aware that there are real
life consequences to this how do you
deal with those
i'm assuming judgmental
uh things that will come up in your life
it's difficult because like your
grandmother probably
right now
my father was
the hardest one my mother's actually
really receptive and their other half of
my family uh cut me off completely which
was unexpected uh the other half
it's kind of a mix where they accept it
we just don't discuss it which i think
is if that's if you don't agree with it
then that's fine we don't have to
discuss it um no one needs to know how
my day was in my family but my father is
an attorney and he's very open-minded
himself but
again it was back to that same scenario
with the professor where i feel like he
thinks it's wasted potential and that
stigma comes to your mind
where
he's looking at me as less than and i
see it in his eyes he's just riddled
with disappointment
and he does not understand it at all
and that's something that's really
difficult to deal with
but
having those conversations those
difficult conversations and telling them
like i'm happy i'm healthy my son
is well taken care of and i'm working to
provide a life for him
that will be unimaginable your son lives
with you he does love me i have a
hundred percent custody of my son so i
am a single mother and he has um
cerebral palsy and epilepsy
so he has special needs and which is a
full-time job in itself so i'm trying to
build this brand and have a lucrative
career and
um
and also make sure that my son is well
provided a very interesting life it's
very interesting it's very chaotic how
does all of this affect you emotionally
it's difficult
the judgment from being a porn actress
the the son whose special needs
you know when i i've gone through
different
like checkpoints in my life of being
more patient and tolerant and
um
the first one was deciding to do porn
and then hearing my son's diagnosis
that was
probably the biggest turning point in my
life that really changed my perspective
i've always had a unique perspective but
and have been empathetic and probably
more so than any other person i've ever
met but that really just grounded me
completely
and
then i
after the stroke
i started having really serious
depression because i have um aphasia
permanent aphasia from that so
my life was already difficult to manage
as it was what's that aphasia aphasia
what is that it's memory loss so i deal
with consistent memory loss sometimes i
don't remember the day
i definitely wouldn't remember what i
did three days ago unless i wrote it
down it's confirmed that this was from
the coveted yes vaccinations yes there's
mixed opinions about it but
the majority of the doctors that i have
that came to the conclusion that's what
it was from the only other option that
they suggested was from covet itself but
that didn't make sense when i had
coveted six months right you've been
perfectly healthy or perfectly healthy
no drugs no no drugs no i drink for sure
but they
didn't think that that was a factor i
don't have high blood pressure there
were no other medical issues that you
know i would have that
would contribute to that
so
i actually
started drinking really heavily after
the stroke which is the opposite thing
that you should do when you have a
stroke by the way
but i fell into
this really severe depression and
anxiety and at one point several months
ago i contemplated suicide for the first
time
and that was a really interesting
experience i was standing in the kitchen
and i was having just a full-blown
mental breakdown and i was drunk and
just miserable
and i had reached a breaking point i
pushed i never recovered after my stroke
i never allowed myself the time to
recover that i needed because i couldn't
i had i have to be
be super mom and you know i have to keep
working i can't stop doing this you know
there are too many people that rely on
me
and in doing so i buried myself too deep
and sometimes that happens where you
reach that point and when you're riding
the tracks at 100 miles an hour towards
a cliff you might go over the edge at
some point
so i did and i was standing in the
kitchen i had a wine opener in my hand
and i the darkest moment in my life was
i literally thought about just shoving
it into my throat
and i
was
a hair away from actually doing it
and that
put a lot of things into perspective for
me too
it's like
you have to take care of yourself
um your mental health is so critically
important and we in america especially
it's ignored often and when you have
invisible illnesses like that i have um
and a lot a lot of people have a
majority of the population has some form
of invisible illness so
it's a vast majority but
it's a silent vast majority for the most
part because they're and again there's
shame and stigma attached to that so
opening up these things and i share
these things publicly because i think
it's critically important that people
have those conversations that are
difficult to have so that we can get
awareness and provide resources and have
access to medical care and you know
mental health care
it's so important to do so again i
sacrifice
those intimate moments in my life that i
probably wouldn't most people would
never tell anyone that or want anyone to
know that and i don't feel shame in that
i hope that
it's relatable and that it's something
that people can overcome as i did too
so it's all a learning experience and if
people can live vicariously through me
then i hope it helps to some degree
is there something in your personality
that
maybe you've always had since you were
young
it just makes you want to venture where
no one else has gone before definitely
um that's right that's what i see
it does
it's very much so uh biological
um
you're very courageous thank you thank
you i sometimes don't feel like it but
thank you i um i've had it since i was a
child and
these life events have only reinforced
it i think though not saying that i
handle every situation appropriately but
every situation that i have that
you know is adverse i use it as a moment
for learning
and
how can i better myself or use this to
help other people in the sense too and
that's always been my first priority
so
i hope it does help at some point that's
great do you have any regrets in your
life
no i don't you know that's all
what's this no regrets um
i think it's okay to have regrets but i
think that
every situation that i've been in that's
been negative
has led to something more positive or
it's built
my foundation
to be stronger to withstand other things
that i experienced down the line and so
therefore i'm actually very thankful for
those moments as tragic as they may be
as difficult as they are as painful as
they are
they're beautiful moments if you look at
them that way as an opportunity to grow
yourself and
to really
slow down and actually listen to
yourself too and maybe
rearrange your plans um
and strategize differently for the next
time around so every moment
that's dark
is something that i use
as a tool to better myself
and i even use it creatively too so i
definitely get a lot of inspiration from
those painful moments in life that i try
to turn into something beautiful so
that's great
thank you misha what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life
the most important lesson that i've
learned in my life
i think it would be
to
not be so hard
on yourself or take what other people
say
about you too seriously i was bullied
for most of my life
and hence why i turned to those
beautiful women that were powerful
figures
i'm teaching my son this every day also
your career doesn't define you your
money your success all of those things
are not real
what you have at the end of the day
is you your character and that's how
people will remember you
were you a compassionate person were you
a kind person were you giving
are you happy in your life those are
things
that no one can take away from you as
much as they want to
they'll never be able to take that away
from you and if you have those things as
a strong foundation
all these other superficial things don't
matter and once you strip that away what
do you have at the end of the day
so to me the most important thing in
life is how i'm going to be remembered
and
if the half the world doesn't agree with
what i do for a living
at the end of the day no one can say
that i was a bad person hopefully
so those are things that i'm trying to
instill in my son as well so how we
leave this world is the most important
thing
and i think that's the most beautiful
thing about life too and i wish more
people would
would see that so if they saw that then
if
people had more compassion
and didn't focus their heavily on hatred
and anger
then
the world would be such a more beautiful
happy place so if i can do it and spread
a little bit of that then at least we're
working towards something positive
that's great
nisha thank you so much for sharing your
story thank you mark so interesting sir
thank you thank you it's crazy
yes it is
you